well i have to tell you everybody at e.t
absolutely screamed holy moly
when you dropped the most unbelievably
romantic
and beautiful wedding thank you
and jeezy what a moment i'm just curious
you know you're about like three months
into marriage now
how is married life and how does it feel
different oh my god
married life feels 1 000 different than
when we were dating in the greatest way
i loved our dating life because
we really spent such concentrated
quality time getting to know each other
and making sure that we were right for
each other
but now being married it's even more
handheld with such delicacy and such
thoughtfulness
because we're in our 40s we both grew up
in households that weren't
healthy marriages and we also have never
seen what that looks like
but in our intuition we all know what we
want we want to feel trusted we want to
feel
loved we want to feel safe we want to
feel cuddles we want to feel
you know the romance we want to feel
dating want to be hot and heavy with sex
like you want all those things so
human beings want those same things why
can't you communicate
exactly what that should look like in
order to customize the relationship you
have and work towards it
and so the fact that i'm doing that with
a partner that is like-minded with me is
the best part of my life you posted
something the other day
that you never stopped dating your
spouse yeah how are you and jay really
prioritizing that
oh that's so funny that you say that
because today you know we're coming to
the end of the week and he had just
flown out for
a show in chicago and he looked at me
before he took off again to another long
day of work
and he said tomorrow don't book anything
i've got you
and i'm like ooh immediately i'm already
thinking about what am i gonna wear
well i can't wait to you know wear these
waves tomorrow because he doesn't get to
see my hair curly or
you know i'm already planning it as i'm
here sitting in work with you
because just something like that from
your spouse immediately like
set something for you to look forward to
because of the intention
to date me even though we live in the
same home and we're going to
bed in the same room you know so that
and then it eggs me on to think oh i
can't wait to for my next date with him
like i can't wait to whisk him off his
feet
and surprise him and i think that that
zeal to continuously
surprise each other and and make each
other look forward to things we'll send
each other love notes and messages and
voice texts
so that that i think you've got to keep
that consistent in order to keep it
strong
welcome to the real well
today's the day people the gang's all
here
we are super excited to finally bring
[Music]
we've seen so many incredible women join
your panel over the past couple years
is there a part of you that would like
to see the show get back to its original
um five co-host panelist lineup
um do you have any names in mind because
you know fans are really
really here for a kiki palmer or even a
raven simone joining adrian that would
be a moment
well the cool thing about the reel is
that it's an open table
we welcome anybody who really has a
voice and something important to share
especially if we can learn from it
and be influenced by it but right now
we barely just got garcelle and i
haven't even seen her in person
like i haven't seen any of the girls for
almost two years now
so i want to get to know garcelle my new
co-host i want to like
spend some time with her really just
like get to know her
role and her position in our show you
know
this last season was kind of too short
so even though the table's open for
anybody to join i still want to get to
know my girl garcelle
i cannot believe you haven't seen your
girls in real life
it's crazy is there a plan to reunite
when will
you see each other in person yeah there
i'm sure we're going to set something up
we just wrapped up this season so we're
all kind of like taking a second from it
but i'm pretty sure that we'll make
something happen and when we do you guys
will find out about it
you're on holy moly you're on the real
you're so established in so many things
that you do
what is next on your bucket list that
you'd really love to to challenge
yourself
and and tackle yeah well i am excited to
design and create
so in order to get that get that
in in um in my blood i've actually
started
uh alcohol beverage company that i've
co-founded with another
group of amazing females who've created
owl's brew so it's the first
ever t seltzer it's a hard cheese
seltzer and it's
delicious refreshing so ready for summer
and the second thing is my first ever
clothing line that's going to come out
this
october and it's going to be for women
who are just like what you said about me
working dating trying to look hot
for themselves with their girls for
their men going on vacation building
companies
so i can't wait for the genie my
clothing line and owl's brew that's
coming up this summer
if anyone was born to have a clothing
line it is you jeannie my dad thank you
i appreciate
that maybe maybe baby
no way
holy moly 3d in 2d i'm
curious how are you raising the stakes
this season
man i i can't believe
after doing season one and two that the
executive producers
and abc's permission allowed us to take
this to an even
crazier level dude we have a hole that
has
explosive huge kernels of popcorn
that are literally socking people
everywhere on their head body legs toes
into a huge pit of corn which was my
personal favorite hole
we also have a hole called po po pole
that involves a pole that's all i'm
gonna say
and um holy matrimony i think that was
crazy the fact that these guys
actually took an a sacred
wedding scene like you've got the aisle
and you've got the efficient and you've
got the ring and the wedding cake
and they turned it into a hole where
you've got to run down a speeding
treadmill
fight this rotating diamond ring and
possibly land with your face
like head first into a piece of cake the
rules have been completely thrown out
the window abc
i i don't know i i don't know like let's
celebrate this because i'm i'm gonna be
really shocked if we're allowed to come
back but hey hey the crazier thing is
just when i think a hole is insane
yeah how many people come beating down
our door to be on the show
from every age from every part of
america moms
grandmothers uh couples siblings
everybody everybody wants to be a part
of the show and that's where i'm like
who are you people like what look
i know that everybody wants to be on
this show and i know girl you got a lot
of important people in that cell phone
of yours
if there was to be a celebrity edition
of holy moly who are your top three
celebrity contestants that you would
love to see participate
okay number one would be michelle obama
because i just think like
she's got so much grace and so much
style that i would love to see how she
would take this on
dozier cat would be really fun i just
think dozier cats so already i mean her
outfits are already so on par with our
whole style
at holy moly where everything goes she's
she's a perfect match
and then i think i'd love to see joe
biden
like he's got something in there he's
ready for this
yeah and you know he'd bring kamala with
him so that would be like a twofer tom
was a girl from the bay i'm not
worried about her she killed correct
[Music]
correct